thank you
i'm going to start by reading some
verses from the church of england psalm
for this evening psalm
which seems appropriate
i waited patiently for the lord
he inclined to me and heard my cry
he brought me out of the pit
out of the mire and the clay
and he set my foot upon a rock and made
my footing sure
so let us pray
father god we cry out to you in prayer
for our nation
at this time of trouble and uncertainty
we pray for wisdom for our national
leaders and their advisors
as they assess what response is required
to the coronavirus
we pray for all in our local community
who've already suffered so much over
these last months
isolation
mental health needs
and we also continue to pray for all who
are grieving
following the deaths of loved ones
as we prepare to celebrate christmas may
your hope
your peace and your love surround all in
our community
all we care for
set every foot upon a rock
make every footing sure
and we give thanks this evening for all
who serve our local community in
whatever way
we pray for wisdom and discernment for
all who hold office within this district
council as councillors and directors
and so almighty god from whom comes
every good and perfect gift
we pray this meeting will be conducted
in a spirit of justice and truth
wisdom and charity
we pray that mindful of their
responsibilities
and the needs of those they serve every
counsellor may use their influence in
this meeting to promote the building up
of community and neighborhood
help them to seek the way of love and
peace
through who him who is the prince of
peace
jesus christ
amen
thank you uh
kennen
nick
rowan for the prayers and welcome to
this meeting um
i will now ask
nick rowan to leave thank you
please be seated members
members when i invite you to speak
please wait until there is a microphone
in front of you before speaking as
microphones are needed for the hearing
loop and for the audio recording
please use the antibacterial wipes if
you do not touch them if you do touch
the microphones
members
voting will be done on a show of hands
in line with the constitution
is this any better
thank you
voting will be done on a show of hands
in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands
then against recommendations
then for abstaining
given the size of this room
given the size of this room and the
numbers of us present
can i please ask that you put your hand
up clearly
high in the air
so that it can be easily seen
by all and leave it up until i ask you
to do to lower it
members
before we turn to the business of this
evening
it's appropriate i think for all of us
to emphasize the fact that we're all
very sensitive to the sad loss of
counsellor craig canel
we will hold a minute silence for him at
next week's council meeting and there
will be an opportunity for us all to pay
tribute to him
at that meeting
this is in line with the wishes of his
family that this should happen after his
funeral service which is scheduled for
the 6th of december
apologies for absence
members we have received
apologies for absence from
councillor macpherson
councillor pavlin
councillor tony carter
councillor michael hoy councillor tracy
knight
councillor june lumley
councillor christine mason councillor
david berrick
and councillor carol weston
members are there any declarations of
interest
members as you know we had to suspend
the council meeting of the 2nd of
november so this evening we will be
starting the meeting from the point that
we left off last time
if you recall
we agreed to change the order of
business for the meeting
and dealt with item 12 the asset
delivery program first
we dealt with
all public
questions and members questions on
notice
relating to item 12 and we dealt with
emotional notice from councillor reeves
relating to item 12 which was presented
in councillor reeves absence and fully
debated
members
councillor eves has in advance of
tonight's meeting we've drawn his motion
given the unique circumstances
i would therefore like to invite
councillor eves to speak now
councillor reeves
members the association of my motion on
notice
with the death of our friend and
colleague
councillor craig cannell cannot be
denied
therefore i feel at this point in time
it is not conducive
or respectful to his memory
continue to continue with my motion on
notice and therefore
ask that it be withdrawn
thank you thank you councillor reeves
okay
madam chairman given the background of
such sad circumstances
i hope all members here tonight will
join me personally in commending
councillor eves
for his dignity and respect in so
gracefully withdrawing his motion
this is very much appreciated by us all
thank you
thank you councillorton
moving on to agenda item 12 asset
delivery program
members please note that we are joined
this evening by mr mark cook of anthony
con
anthony collins solicitors for this item
members
i would remind you that there are three
exempt appendices to the report
does anyone need to make reference to
any of these exempt appendices or ask
any specific questions on them please
we will need to move the agreed
motion
okay
i will now ask the leader of the council
to introduce the report
thank you madam chairman and firstly i
should like to thank our team of
officers and advisors for the
preparation of
and the detailed contents of the report
and appendices at item 12 before you
tonight
as i've already publicly said
in the run-up to this meeting
i'm proud that this council has been
visionary and forward thinking
in leading the asset delivery program
the program will deliver high quality
modern and functional facilities in
buildings which are financially
sustainable
and are of an exceptionally high
standard of environmental sustainability
buildings in which for years to come
we can have civic pride for the
residents we serve
the program reflects the council's 2018
asset strategy objectives to regenerate
and transform the local area and our
community facilities
and is part of our ongoing duty as
members of this council to reduce
pressure on the public purse
at the outset as leader of rochefort
district council
i made a promise that we would listen to
all representations made to our original
proposals and we have done exactly that
i also said we would publish the
feedback received during the engagement
process and working with our development
partner gb partnerships we did just that
i want to reassure members and the
public that we have heard feedback about
the importance of the windmill and the
mount and also the green spaces locally
important trees
and concerns about residential
development
we've also heard the concerns raised
about the replacement of the mill hall
itself
working with gb partnerships we have
engaged with all the relevant statutory
and non-statutory consultees who would
be part of any planning process
and all the stakeholders who have been
part of the mill hall's use i want to
reassure everyone that is an ongoing and
genuine dialogue which we will continue
going forward
i said in a statement issued on the 22nd
of september this year
that we would reflect and consider the
feedback and bring a further report to
council
and that is the report before you this
evening members
the report this evening provides an
update on the progress of the asset
delivery program
and sets out two options for members to
consider following public feedback
received from the engagement exercise on
the mill arts and event center site
i am proud that at a time when other
authorities within this region are
closing or reviewing their ability to
deliver leisure facilities and reducing
their community spaces
quite contrary this council has been
visionary and ambitious and proactive in
bringing forward proposals for its
assets
not only in this program but more widely
to ensure they are fit for purpose
future proofed and offer the highest
standards in environmental
sustainability
by now members will have read the report
and that is why in response to strong
representations and feedback by the
public and given my previous public
commitments to listen and act
responsibly
i am proposing recommendation 2
as set out at 13.1
page 12.9 of tonight's agenda which says
to revisit the council's requirements
for the mill arts and event center site
and agree that a separate outline
business case to include a full options
analysis be undertaken and the results
brought back to council for approval
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillor whitten do we have
a second year for that
counsellor drey
thank you chairman
as chairman
as chairman of the partnership panel
it's not on sonia is it on
is that better thank you
madam chairman
as chairman of the partnership panel
i wish to support the statement and
commitments of council wooden
and i'm happy to second the proposal to
accept recommendation 2
to visit the council's requirements for
the mill arts and event center site
should recommendation 2 be agreed the
partnership panel
will continue to have a significant and
important part to play in the
development of the outline business case
for the mill hall site
the partnership panel will not only
therefore continue its current work but
will also participate in the proposed
community essential work stream
the partnership panel will continue to
be chaired by an elected member and will
remain cross party as will the community
centre work stream
the pilot ship panel has received
numerous presentations from offices
advisors and gp partnership and will
continue to do so it being a crucial
part of the governance of the asset
delivery program providing constructive
challenge by providing recommendations
and ideas to the partnership board
through the partnership panel members
have had and will continue to have the
opportunity to help shape the future of
the council's assets to ensure they
deliver the council's objectives for
environmental and financial
sustainability whilst taking into
account the results of the public
and stakeholders engagement processes
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillor dre
sorry
okay
members
please
during the debate
if you need to ask a question or make
reference to any of the exempt
appendices
we will need to take them at the end of
the debate
so that we can exclude the press and
public
um
i've
almost ripped up what i was going to say
because
it's nice to see the leader uh proposing
option two um right from the start
excuse me councillor will concern can
you just check it they're not working
a bit closer apologies um yes it was
nice to see the leader propose option
two right from the start and not
unsurprising
um
i do have a couple of points i'd like to
make if i may um and
they will come as no surprise to the
leader because he and i have spoken
about this um i am
i am disappointed if i'm honest with you
that there is still no mention of the
civic suite because the civic suite is
was subject to the public feedback
um it's uh within the same ward as the
mill hall and art center still within
the town center rayleigh the public
made it quite clear they don't want any
housing there at all and yet it's not
mentioned in option two um and i'm a
little bit concerned that the options
have been brought before members tonight
don't give us enough leeway
to discuss that
equally i'm concerned
that
whilst i i understand that gb
partnerships
the jb partnerships have a degree of
autonomy in what they're doing
why is it
that the
administration who have say they listen
to what the public feedback is saying
why have you allowed gb partnerships to
bring this option one forward because
surely
you should have turned around to them
and looked at it and said what the hell
is this this doesn't bear any relevance
whatsoever to public feedback could go
away and start again and give us some
proper options to vote on tonight
i am concerned that had that not been
done in that in that in that sense we
might be in a position now where we
don't have to fork out
over 140 000 pounds
to look at revisiting the mill hall
because it could have been something
that could have been dealt with during
option one
um and i think that's something that's
going to have to be addressed at some
point but to conclude chairman i would
like to now that the motion has been
moved and seconded um i want to move an
amendment to the motion please um and i
will seek some advice from yourself any
other member here who wants to help with
this i have already spoken to the
monitoring officer about this yesterday
but i would like to amend option two
so that every place within option two
the mention of the mill arts and event
center we include the words and the
civic suite site as well
because i would like that to be included
with option two for consideration please
thank you councillor wilkinson
[Applause]
do you
do you have a seconder
thank you councillor lawman
thank you chairman i'm talking to myself
here with me every day um yeah thank you
chairman um compliance to the leader i
agree with everything that my colleague
has said
um
i'm a little bit i must have been i'm a
bit sort of suspicious if that might be
this maybe a strong word but we are
putting in to put this off but is this
simply a delay i i just
would like to have say heard the motion
that we are not
going forward with this plan and we'll
review it but it doesn't say that we're
just going to consider what other
options but i do wish to second the
motion
for councillor wilkinson and put that
motion forward thank you
thank you council lawman
[Applause]
councillor newport
thank you chairman
um yes i wholeheartedly agree with them
councillor wilson's amendment to uh
emotion
so we'll concentrate
um
reading the report
made my heart sink
our residents have respectfully given
their views during the public engagement
and it's blindingly obvious that they
outright reject the redevelopment of the
mill
arts and event center and
rayleigh civic suite
is not acceptable tonight that we are
asked to
what i consider throwing residents of
bone with either of these options which
does not include
the civic suite
as it stands
option one
is very very bad and option two
is very bad
officers are trying to make the best of
a bad decision as i see it
on page 12.3 paragraph 3.5
it is not possible either gb
partnerships or offices to directly
address either of the
feedback because of the council's
requirements and that was referring to
the residential development
the output specification approved by the
investment board
was on the 5th of september 2019.
in accordance with previous decisions of
the investment board and council are set
out in paragraph 2.1 above officers
therefore have no powers to depart
from the mandate previously given by
members without further permission from
the council
simply put our offices are powerless to
alter the situation
unless members here tonight
allow them to
my guess is the administration will not
will not alter things despite the public
opinion
options presented
to to us just go to show
that unfortunately the administration is
still not listening
clearly enough to what the residents
are asking for
it should admit its failings now and
reopen the community facilities
that it holds rayleigh to ransom with
castle road
hall the mill hall and rayleigh civic
suite
there is no alternative option then to
remove these sites from the asset
delivery programme
and scale back the delusions of grandeur
thank you chairman thank you councillor
newport do we have any other speakers
for this debate
councillor wilson
thank you chairman
um
as council newport said this was
originally approved in 2019
and the world moves on unless does our
understanding
so
while the original concept uh had a high
brienne standard which i think is good
is very laudable
but what we should be looking at is the
wider environmental impact of
demolishing a building rather than
reusing it and what i would value is
that when we revisit this that we look
at the environmental impact given our
carbon neutral policies thank you
thank you councillor wilson
councillor reeves
[Music]
thank you i have been involved with the
project
from the investment board to the current
partnership panel and have tried to give
positive engagement throughout the
process
i have actively questioned the direction
of the contract award to the designs
that have been presented
there was a stage at which i requested
the council to consider pausing the
project
to allow the effect of the pandemic to
be considered in the changes that were
inevitably due to come about
as the work standards and space
requirements would be reconsidered
as commerce emerges from crovid
the council decided to reject my
considered request
i have since been castigated publicly
for having done that and recently not
supported the pause that was
unilaterally declared by the
conservative group at election time
i would point out if the matter had been
brought to the council for a decision at
that time
to pause as per protocol i would have
had no hesitation in supporting it
the manner in which this was done in my
view showed a total disregard for the
constitution and protocol of council
that's why i have questioned the
declaration made by the conservatives
without reference to the council
from the first conversations that were
had over the asset delivery program
members were told that the asset
delivery program is an all or nothing
project
we were told that many times over
now it seems that it can be varied
following the public outcry regarding
the plans in particular the ones
involving the mill arts and
entertainment center
this leads me to seriously wonder why
the members were told it was an all or
nothing project in the first place
was it to stemi conversation on
alternative strategies
for me
this raises serious questions
now we are asked to consider spending
vast amounts of public money
to vary the project when early
conversations could have easily
prevented the situation we now find
ourselves in
this leads me to seriously question the
advice that we have been and are being
given over the direction of the project
so i'm afraid i will be abstaining from
the vote on both options as i remain
unconvinced on the direction of the adp
and i'm concerned
that 147 600 pounds being additionally
voted to be spent after the vote tonight
will not be the end of the additional
costs of the project from the public
purse as a result
thank you
thank you councillor reeves
is there any other speakers
okay so just to remind members that we
are um we have been we're going to be
voting
on the amendment that we've just debated
um so members
i'll remind you to raise your hand nice
and high if you are
voting for the amendment
those in favor please raise your hand
thank you
thank you councillors
i'll hand over to sonia
counselor mrs butcher would you like to
vote for against or abstain
counsellor constable
councillor dre
councillor fd
councillor eves
councillor foster
councillor mrs gadsden
councillor james gooding
mrs gooding against
councillor norman
councillor milne
councillor myers
councillor james newport
councillor mrs newport
councillor mrs rowe
councillor mrs shaw
council mr shaw
councillor smith
councillor sparing
councillor stanley
counselor step 2
hansel award
hansa webb
councillor wilkinson
councillor williams
councillor wilson
councillor whitton
members that was 7
4
20
against
motion
is lost
i now invite members to debate the
original motion put forward by
councillor wooden
please if you need to reference any of
the example appends any of the exempt
appendices
we will need to take them at the end of
the debate so we can exclude the press
and public
do we have any speakers
councillor stanley
members if if you could please raise
your hand nice and high it would help
for people to see thank you
you chairman and thank you for allowing
me to speak
um i've sat here very quietly listening
to what's been going on um
and i think that uh as a council
we should acknowledge that every one of
us
has
some input into the structure of the
asset delivery
it's been my understanding that
everything comes from
if you'd like to call it the other side
of the fence and i'd like to ask the
leader if he would
put in mind that there are more than one
political party in this
council
and would he
oblige us all by consulting with
maybe the other parties as to where we
are going with our assets thank you
thank you councillor stanley
councillors smith
thank you chairman
possibly contrary to popular belief i do
listen objectively to
all of the various discussions that we
have and the points that are made
and i do believe what what council of
whatton has
put forward tonight is a positive way
forward
given the pause that took place to the
project after listening to public
comment
but i must say chairman i do sometimes
question the commitment of some of the
other parties
in the council
as they seem to want to lock the
district into the past
for some strange reason
they don't seem to want to promote us as
a council operating
fit for purpose energy efficient
buildings
playing our part in with what has
rapidly been
understood as a global crisis
they seem to want to lock us in spirals
of debt
operating uneconomic buildings and that
debt which of course would be funded by
each and every one of our council
taxpayers right across the
district
to keep decrepit buildings rather than
have new ones
to stop investment happening in our
district in the future i just seem to be
hearing the word i don't want i don't
want i don't want time after time
i absolutely believe that what's been
put forward in this asset management
program is about taking the district
forward
the roadmap might be a bit rocky but we
must do it
thank you
thank you councillor smith
councillor wilkinson
[Music]
thank you chairman thank you for letting
me speak again
i wasn't going to speak actually um i'd
said my bits and i was going to allow
others to speak but unfortunately i'm
not going to let that go
i decided i was going to be respectful
tonight and i was not going to be the
way i normally am and i'm not
particularly impressed if i'm honest
with the disrespect as shown by a member
of the executive towards the minority
groups
we don't live our lives in the past we
don't hold on to decrepit buildings
we listen to the public we've listened
to what the public has said personally i
don't live in i don't i wasn't born in
raleigh i have no links with the middle
hall and art center it means nothing to
me personally
but i listen to the residents of my
award it means something to them the
civic suite means something to them and
i look around this room and we're
looking at some of the members that are
up for election next year
and i i'm surprised that the stance
being taken particularly what's just
been said for a member of the executive
and i'm absolutely appalled that a
senior member of this council has spoken
in such terms thank you
thank you council wilkinson
councillor whitton
thank you madam chairman um
there is a process and
as councillor stanley will be well aware
there has been the investment board
which is an official um
convened committee uh through which
there was cross-party contribution and
indeed there's the partnership panel
chaired by councillor dre who indeed is
a wheatley ward councillor
in which particularly the mill hall sits
and that is where there is cross-party
opportunity and actually
along with councillor dre
i ask that a very flexible approach be
taken within the partnership panel so
that all members irrespective of their
political persuasion have the
opportunity to contribute to the debate
so we get the broadest possible
perspective on this
some of the comments that have been made
tonight whilst interesting
appear to me to misunderstand what this
paper is all about
the initial process
started in 2018 was to look
at assets which are no longer viable for
us to either keep or maintain
and we have developed a program
and it talks about six sites
that we wanted to modernize
or dispose of
because over time they have become
superfluous to our needs
so what we have
madam chairman
is a situation where
an outline business case was put
together
which covered six sites
four sites
are superfluous to the council's needs
those are three sites in south street in
rochford and one site in rayleigh
and the funding of the project comes
from regenerating those sites and
providing an income
to generate
superb office facilities for this
council of which we can be proud of
in rochford
and at the same time generate a
community facility
in rayleigh
now what has become patently aware to me
is that the proposal which was in line
with the outline business case
and commercially
met the specification
is not acceptable
principally to the residents of raleigh
and that is why we come back to this
basic point of listening
and i have listened the administration
has listened and indeed all councillors
have listened
irrespective of political persuasion
but we have to develop a program that
will pay for itself
the civic suite however emotive
it might be to dispose
of a
property that historically people have
used is now superfluous to our needs
so
really we're talking about a sensible
project i accept
that what
commercially looked a reasonable
proposition is no longer acceptable to
the people of raleigh particularly on
the mill arts side
and actually if it's not acceptable to
the people of radio it's not acceptable
to me as leader
which is why i have made the statements
that i have consistently
i am listening and i believe that at the
end of the day we will have a community
facility
which
we don't legally actually have to
provide
if you look away from this district
you'll see other authorities closing
their community facilities we're not
doing that we're talking about building
bigger and better
and that is the objective of the report
tonight to produce an outline business
case specifically that looks at the
existing mill hall site
so that we can do better than was
proposed originally
but i'm afraid
the civic suite is superfluous to our
needs given that the
main headquarters of this authority will
be in rochford albeit
that part of the community facility is
also to provide touchdown space for our
officers to serve the residents of
raleigh
thank you very much indeed madam
chairman thank you councillorton
councillor lawman
thank you chairman
i don't want this to become personal and
it's always a danger that might happen
but i want to talk on a general scale
rayleigh and i've heard it's about
rochford and it's going to be at
rochford i've heard those comments but
rayleigh represents over half of this
district
don't shake your head it's a fact
there's over 50 000 people residing
rightly
and if you point that out that is over
half of the district the rest is spread
over other parishes
now when you we had a paper came out
originally and it was published as
publicity there was discussion or
comments made about the new local plan
that's going forward in 2025.
the opening statements there make a
comment about radius saying it's got a
central hub it's got the infrastructure
and that's why we've got to have all the
housing because it's the central most
productive area of all of the district
there was comments made in there and
they're in writing
so if you've got that you've got one bus
that goes to rockford we forget that
this council is a service provider we're
not a business we're not a blue chip
company i understand and respect
the issues about saving money about
being economic i do respect those
comments
but we're selling off the silver
and we are disregarding the
environmental and social issues in this
town with the the whole structure of
this town is about his history about the
dynamics of the town we want to
encourage businesses and you can get
you're putting the whole core of this
management in rockford a sleepy little
town
and with one bus
and all i'm saying is
part of this you can shake your head you
can do it a lot but i'm having my say
i've got the floor and all i'm saying is
that you're all we seem to be obsessed
with housing and flats
the amount of blocks of flats have gone
up in this town over the last five years
is unprecedented
and you say that we don't need a hall we
don't need entertainment
we don't need this we don't need that
but we need all these flats because it's
economically sound
the people the people they're looking at
they're laughing
the point is that the people of this
town
want to be represented and they want to
be listened to
and i'm referencing that and i want to
be heard because when we look at the
future of the bill hall i have no
confidence that all we're doing at the
moment is we're talking about deferring
this this subject
for all i know this is all gonna because
you're talking about economics and the
plan and all the costs and how we're
looking to sell off this because what
build debt that gives me no confidence
that bill hall and that site will not
end up with blocks of flex he will not
end up with housing and it won't be a
clue struck a close structure
we are losing this town
i was only a few weeks or months ago now
i wasn't part of this original plan
because i was a tent councillor and i
wasn't elected at that time i lost my
seat so i was no part of this this
project and i've read as much as i can
and looked at it from afar i've tried to
understand it and some of it's been
difficult
and all i'm saying is i'm speaking for
this town i've been here since 1967 i've
seen the changes i'm not having to go we
need changes we've had differences
but we must listen to the people
the people that live here that pay for
all of this who pay good money to live
in this town and we're being ignored
so when we look at the project from afar
i want you to consider that well you
know that
rayleigh
has a heart
a very strong beating heart if we want
to encourage people to this dad we have
to provide facilities
because there will come a time when it
won't have his appeal and i don't want
to live over in rockford action or
anywhere else
and i'm sorry but i feel very strongly
about this and i have to speak to that
for the people that have spoken to me
thank you thank you councillor
[Applause]
councillor stanley you have already
spoken and i do want to wind this on a
bit we've got quite a lot of business to
get through tonight
if there's no new speakers counsellor fd
councillor fd
thank you sonia thank you chairman lady
um i'll take a little bit of exception
to this being bailey district council
it's nice to watch for district council
and what should
is goes all the other to the other side
of the east
and having every thinking radio is not
fair for the residents of rochford and
there is okay this mode is one bus that
goes to raleigh but there's something
called a train which stops right outside
the freight house which hopefully will
be our new
offices which was quicker than the bus
normally
so
as i was part of this from the beginning
as part of the asset development working
party
and of course we've listened to the
people valley on the mill hall which
what we're discussing tonight and
there's never been any suggestion
that there was not going to be some sort
of community centre there
and i'm looking forward to
seeing
a carbon
excellent
community centre there in the future
so i'm giving my support to option two
on this
thank you very much
thank you councillor
there are three more speakers and then
we will take this to the vote
councillor
thank you chairman
first of all we must remember that we're
all here to represent the district and
not just one town of that district
i've at least i have listened here to
all the comments tonight chairman and
it's very easy to throw stones from the
sidelines however i think our leader has
said it all almost an hour ago
and i would totally echo his words thank
you
thank you councillor
councillor foster
thank you chairman um just in response
to council lawman's comment i've not
read anywhere in any report that says
there will be no hall and no
entertainment i think that's just been
made to be said to be controversial
and
there has been respect shown to the
feedback from the public i think
approximately a thousand people out of
eighty thousand
gave responses and that's been given due
attention and has been reacted to thank
you
councillor
ward
thank you
chairman it's uh it's very interesting
because it
on page
12.3
3.11
it says it all about option two
it's their plane in order to revisit the
council's requirements for the mill arts
and event center
site
it would be necessary to commission a
separate online business case for the
site to develop an options analysis and
consider delivery options for the
avoidance of doubt
this would include options for
refurbishment and remodeling now i think
i think that's ever so plain
it's a very simple statement which
actually says that we are going to look
at the mill arts and event center to
ensure it is i would guess a state of
the art whatever that's going to be
because that is the will of the people
of raleigh we are here to defend those
wishes completely and absolutely and i
will stand by that and i will support
this proposal absolutely i'm a rayleight
there's a lot of rayleights in this room
who i'll tell you
are going to be very upset if we do not
do
what the people who really want and they
want a refurbished or
brand new state of the art center and i
will be fully supporting the whole of
this process the way through
and that's the word process that we're
going to follow totally and absolutely
and i hope
i hope the opposition members
are going to support us in this because
it's what they want they are supporting
for rayleigh i am supporting for raleigh
we should be one
for riley thank you very much chairman
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you council award we will now take
this to the vote
please raise your hand if you are for
the motion
the first motion not the amendment we've
already voted on the amendment we are
now voting on option two
if if there's enough people standing up
i will hand over to sonia
okay
first of all i will read out the
recommendation again
to revisit the council's requirements
for the meal arts and event center site
and agree that a separate outline
business case
to include a full options analysis be
undertaken
and the results brought to council for
approval
and those in favor please raise their
hand
no no no no
oh sorry
um
2a
um
mrs butcher please
counsellor constable
councillor dre
councillor fd
councillor eves
councillor foster
councillor mrs gadsden
councillor mr gooding
councillor mrs gooding for
councillor myers
councillor
mr newport
councillor mrs newport
councillor mrs rowe
councillor mrs shaw
councillor mr shaw
councillor smith
councillor sparing
councillor stanley
wilkinson
councillor williams
councillor wilson
councillor whatton
members there was 24
3 against and 4 abstained
therefore i declare that motion is
carried
members it is recommended that 2a is
noted
so 2a then to note the outline business
case addendum exempt appendix 2.
thank you members it is also recommended
that 2d is noted please
thank you members
we now have a further
two recommendations 2b and 2c
tv
to be to authorize and delegate to the
assistant director
assets and commercial
and the assistant director
resources in consultation with the
leader of the council
and the portfolio holder for financial
strategy
to agree any terms to vary the
contractual agreements with gbp
as is necessary to give effect to
recommendation to
those in favor
thank you members
those against
and those abstaining
twenty
four
zero against
and seven abstentions
thank you members finally recommendation
2c
oh sorry recommendation is carried
and we will now move on to 2c to approve
the drawdown from the hard soft
infrastructure reserve
of a hundred and forty seven thousand
six hundred to fund activities as set
out in table two
in section nine point three
we will now take a vote on that those in
favor
please please lower your hands those
against
and abstentions
twenty
four
two against and four abstentions
that motion is carried
thank you members
that concludes that item of business
i will now turn to item four on the
agenda
oh just one moment
mr mark cook if you would like to leave
now take your leave
counselor wilkinson
it's been noted
councillor wilkinson if you want to take
something outside the meeting that's
fine
it's already been noted
i will now turn to agenda item 4.
which is
the chairman's announcement
i was honored to attend a memorial
service held in remembrance of sir david
amis mp in south end on the 22nd of
november i have visited many voluntary
organizations and businesses to lend my
support and raise awareness of the
wonderful facilities available in our
district
one of these included memory lane cafe
which is a voluntary group held for
carers and their loved ones living with
dementia
this is held at hockley day centre
where i visited the clients who were
enjoying an afternoon of entertainment
socialising
and afternoon tea
at the opposite end of the age spectrum
i was pleasantly impressed to see in
excess of 50 young people
in attendance at chaos fab youth club
in stanbridge
to see youngsters playing football
cooking learning skills and socializing
in a safe environment was really
encouraging
i've learned that their membership has
since increased to 75 members
i was also privileged
to attend the official opening of the
rochford district heritage tapestry at
raley town museum
this is a most unique community project
consisting of ten panels of handcrafted
tapestry
depicting significant events and local
history of our district
over the past thousand years
put together by over 200 participants
children and adults
which was exhibited at rayleigh museum
this has subsequently moved to rochford
parish council offices where it is
available for viewing
that concludes the chairman's update
and i will now
turn to agenda item five
public questions and members questions
on notice
members
the questions from councillor tracy
knight and council tony carter are
deferred to the next meeting
councillor wilkinson can i invite you to
read out your questions to the leader
please
thank you chairman
rocha oh sorry
watch your district council has reached
out to the residents of rocha district
for their views on the current sites
being considered as part of the new
local plan
in a letter to the right honourable
robert generic mp dated the 9th of
november 2020 the leader of the council
together with the portfolio hold for
planning and the chair of the planning
policy subcommittee urged the
governments to rethink the way in which
housing targets are set for the future
and also states there is already a huge
strain on the local infrastructure
i am sure that all members will agree
with this statement because i certainly
do
we already see our road network at a
standstill gp's surgeries unable to cope
and patients are unable to obtain a
simple doctor's appointment
schools are at capacity and in some
cases in excess of their capacity
my question chairman is does the leader
of the council agree with me that before
any more housing is delivered within our
district infrastructure needs to be
addressed to that end
can you please explain to this council
what his administration is doing to
ensure that proper and improved
infrastructure measures are incorporated
within the new local plan so that rocha
district has the infrastructure to
enable us to deliver the housing we're
being asked for
and secondly
what are the highways council doing
to sorry beggar pardon what are the
council doing to engage with essex
county council highways department to
ensure suitable road improvements are
made to deliver the housing needs of the
district thank you
thank you councillor wilkinson
councillor worton would you please
respond to the questions
madam chairman thank you very much
indeed and thank you to councillor
wilkinson for his question
the plan making process requires that
all plans promote sustainable patterns
of development that meet the needs of
the area aligning growth with the need
for new infrastructure
improvements to the environment and
mitigation against climate change
the strategy strategic policies in our
new local plan will set out an overall
strategy for the pattern and scale of
development areas in the district
and make sufficient provision for
infrastructure for transport and
community facilities such as health and
education
the new local plan will set out the
contributions expected from development
the planning authority will engage with
developers on those major schemes at
pre-application stage to discuss the
appropriate infrastructure required as a
result of the new developments
it must be accepted that it is the
supply of the larger number of new homes
that best achieve the infrastructure
improvements
specifically in relation to our road
network it is not only road improvements
and junction upgrades that are the
solution these should be complemented by
infrastructure that supports a genuine
choice of transport modes
in addition experienced pressure on our
local doctors surgeries has prompted a
response from the mid essex ccg
who recently met with our officers and
requested that they now be consulted on
all applications of 10 or more dwellings
from now on
as opposed to the current threshold of
50 dwellings
recognizing the demands even small-scale
developments are having on our existing
surgeries and the ccgs need to respond
to this demand
with regard to your second question
transport issues will be considered as
part of the new local plan process
so that any potential impacts from
development on the transport network can
be addressed
part of the plan making process requires
engagement between the planning
authority the communities and
infrastructure providers
joint working with strategic
policy-making authorities is integral to
determining where additional
infrastructure is necessary
but if i come back to your first point
councillor wilkinson
like you
i do agree with the sentiment of your
points and that is why over the past
year i've written three letters
one to
mr generic when he was
minister of state but more recently to
the right honourable
michael gove
i sent that letter on the 1st of
november
just yesterday i received a response to
that letter from the right honourable
christopher pincher mp
and i have asked for
both my letter and that reply to be
posted on members drop tomorrow so that
all members
can see those letters because
they are addressing infrastructure
the
numbers allocation issue and the fact
that decision making should stay with
local authorities rather than be dealt
with centrally
but when we do talk about infrastructure
i just want to come back
to points that i've made regularly
and that is please do not tell me on the
development that by connecting a 12-inch
sewage pipe to a 6-inch sewage pipe that
is real infrastructure it is not what we
want to see is genuine infrastructure
and that really relates to digital
connections
fibre broadband water services sewage
services
and
certainly through the nhs community
facilities you name it it's genuine
needs but it comes through different
agreements section 106 and larger scale
developments
but i do want also to point you
to the the roundabout at roareth lane
and holbridge road
for me that is a genuine piece of
infrastructure which has gone in which
has actually genuinely alleviated
traffic congest congestion in an area
quite remote from the development and
the developers are actually part paid
for it and that is a good example so
before we talk ourselves down whilst i
totally don't want to take anything away
from the points that you're making i do
want to acknowledge that infrastructure
does go in
and sometimes it goes in and we just
take it a bit for granted but i do share
your concern
and i will continue to press through
this administration for exactly the
point that you're making thank you
thank you councillor wootton
councillor wilkinson do you have a
supplementary question
agenda item six
business from last meeting
members does anyone have any questions
relating to business from the council
meeting held on the 20th of july 2021
no thank you
agenda item 7
to note the minutes of the executive and
committee meetings held between the
period 7th of july 2021
to the 5th of october 2021
are these noted members
thank you
agenda item 8 to consider any reports
from the executive and committee to
council
members there are none
on to agenda item 9 report on urgent
decisions
is this noted members
thank you
agenda item 10 report of the leader on
the work of the executive
is this noted members
agenda item 11
motions on notice
members
the motions on notice from councillor
christine mason councillor james newport
and councillor lisa newport are deferred
to the next meeting
i now conclude the meeting ends at 20
42. thank
and chief you